passons cinq heures ensemble ça sera
peut-être plus quatre heures et demie
que cinq heures mais en tout cas ça avec
quelques bonnes heures ensemble
[Musique]
je vous explique le truc il ya quelques
mois philips m'a contacté philippe
thieuw m'a contacté en disant voilà
monsieur gros aurélien on voudrait faire
un événement pour parler de la lumière
connectés et on veut le faire de
différentes manières et notamment
voudraient faire avec toi et on va le
faire sur deux jours alors il ya une
journée qui est plus presse
professionnelle en c1 ce qui nous
stresse un petit peu parce que j'ai pu
retrouver à parler devant la presse
devant beaucoup de titres de presse
je suis pas habitué moi c'est plutôt de
l'autre côté à prendre des notes à
écouter puis à vous tous vous
retranscrire directement en vidéo donc
ça s'arrête un peu stressant pour moi
mais ça c'est vachement intéressant je
vous raconterai sera probablement une
prochaine fois et ça c'est le vendredi
et le samedi
eh bien j'ai toute une journée à toute
une après-midi à passer avec vous de 14h
à 18h30
on va pouvoir passer du temps ensemble à
pouvoir parler de lumière connectés on
va passer du temps dans un lieu qui est
incroyable qui est à paris qui est à
bastille et ça va être un truc qui va
être vraiment vraiment vraiment génial
alors on aura aussi une petite partie de
consoles on va passer beaucoup de temps
sont vraiment vraiment vraiment cool
plein d'ambiance défaite a rajouté un
petit peu le truc et c'est une maison un
appartement connecté au tour au
construit autour de philippe sion enfin
vous verrez ils sont retranscrits et
tout ça en vidéo je vous dis donc pas
sont cinq heures ensemble parce qu'au
fait qu'il va y avoir quelques personnes
qui vont pouvoir venir de par la
capacité du lieu c'est pas une rencontre
abonnés sans le fera plus tard en
l'organisera différemment là c'est
vraiment une paix qui est construite en
partenariat avec philip sion donc l'idée
c'est de passer du temps mais a très peu
de personnes
il ya eu huit personnes entre vous avec
qui je pouvoir passer l'après-midi par
est vraiment cool alors le jour je donne
la date très très très très très
précisément peux pas vous dire de
bêtises je sors mon petit calendrier
c'est le samedi 23 novembre quelques
jours avant mes 40 ans le gros challenge
samedi des repas sera peut-être un peu
monté de l'anniversaire de passer du
temps avec vous ça va être vraiment cool
samedi 23 novembre 14h 18h30 ça se passe
à bastille c'est à paris on va faire ça
sous forme de tirage au sort jeu
vous mais un lien en bas d'un
description c'est un petit formulaire
google je vous invite à venir le remplir
avec vos coordonnées et ayant futur à 8
personnes qui vont être tirés au sort le
truc est vraiment très important c'est
que avant même de venir participer en
bas soyez sûr que vous allez pouvoir
être présents le samedi 23 novembre 2019
de 14h à 18h30 à paris à bastille donc
il faut que vous soyez en région
parisienne si vous voulez monter
d'ailleurs en france pour venir ce avec
très grand plaisir
mais elle est engagé des frais pour ça
si maintenant vous voulez faire ça avec
un très grand plaisir que je vous
rencontrerai vous inquiétez pas je sais
que huit personnes ça fait pas beaucoup
je ferai des rencontres abonnés
ultérieurement mail à studio principaux
particulière et qui je pense va être
très sympa donc je vous invite à venir
remplir le formulaire en bas si vous
pouvez venir et si vous êtes sûr vous
pouvez venir y aura un tirage au sort
parmi toutes les personnes qui sont
participantes je pense que ça va être un
truc vraiment cool on va passer un
excellent moment ensemble et pour tous
ceux qui n'ont pas pu être présents et
bien je vous raconterai tout ce qui
s'est passé après en vidéo je vous
relate la journée sponsable vraiment
vraiment vraiment intéressant c'est une
vidéo un petit peu à part non vraiment
c'est l'événement j'espère vous êtes
nombreuses et nombreux à participer
quand pouvoir passer beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de temps ensemble du temps de
qualité
ça va être ibra coule sur se donnent
rendez vous dès demain pour continuer à
parler tech nous embrasse ciao